there's this brain training facility
that helps you rewire your brain
increase IQ boost creativity grow a huge
mustache it doesn't really say that but
it doesn't say it doesn't their usual
clientele is billionaires CEOs top
celebrities and now
myself but on a serious note I've always
hated the idea of being average just
being like everyone else
but what if you could become exceptional
gifted different my friend RAF and I
signed up for the five-day intensive
training and if we had known what we got
ourselves into we wouldn't have signed
up for this
Hello
whoa you feel the energy in here man it
is like still
what does this training look like you're
gonna go into this chamber it's going to
be soundproof like proof and you have
electrodes on your head 14-hour days
inside the chamber and debriefing back
and forth back and forth back and forth
what happens to the brain is the
equivalent of if you've meditated for 40
years 11.7 increase in IQ is the average
so the crazy thing about IQ is like
three to four points it's gonna make a
massive difference in how you view the
world so we also took an IQ test before
and after to see how much increased what
did I miss Hello
nice to meet you yeah this handsome
fella is Brian our main instructor for
the next five days
what is this this is our Chambers oh
yeah this looks like a torture chamber
and this dark freezing room our brains
are going to be hooked up to a
neurofeedback device the goal of this
training is to learn how to get into a
high alpha brainwave State at will which
is a state in which you have relaxed
highly creative and no problem can't be
solved our brain's Alpha ways will be
measured and converted into sound in
real time the higher the waves the
louder the sounds so we can hear whether
we're doing it right and every two
minutes we see scores of our Alpha Waves
you'll go as deep as you allow yourself
to go
and with that
and we'll begin the journey and your
first enhancement today when you're
enhancing Alpha have fun get used to the
tone to get used to your brain good luck
I wish you the best
you know it's in these moments you ask
yourself what have I gotten myself into
you gotta come back right you're gonna
get me out
the way I see this is that we are
getting a human upgrade it's like in
Captain America where he goes into the
chamber and it comes out different human
we're gonna be different people remember
you are in control of the times we're
just measuring the brainwebs his
amplitudes you can see are starting to
shoot up
they've been in there for about 90
minutes now it's crazy it's listening to
tones I feel like their brain is going
to be fried by the time they come out
[Music]
this is a wild you just
try out different things to get your
brain to respond and then you get the
feedback and you're like oh I think I
did it right I had a completely
different experience yeah I found it's
so difficult what was the thing that
helped you I don't know if I want to
share my secret sauce
yeah let's talk to him yeah see what he
says this is canopy room so after your
session is over you come in here you
talk about your experience how was it to
hear your brain for the first time
um I was a little overwhelming or
confusing at first I was like okay let's
feel good or think about the goals that
I want to work on or didn't work do you
think his brain waves are average below
average I mean surely not above average
and then it's not a comparison it's
exactly but what I'm always saying but
if you were to compare next up we are
doing a bunch of forgiving five
instances people things that we want to
forgive I thought we were here to
increase our IQ
but supposedly this increases your Alpha
brain waves a lot I'm gonna go over the
bio server not forgiveness protocol this
is something they'll be done in the
chamber as you release emotional tension
through forgiveness process it frees up
your Alpha could it be something you've
done or something someone did to you
yeah you want to feel the pain as we
keep going you'll trigger a lot of
things and a lot more things will come
up good luck let's do it another session
we're about to begin with our second set
of mouth enhancement this is where you
are going to forgiveness all right Leon
let's hear about what you did
forgiveness yep who's the first charge
oh my dad you're dead all right and what
was the judge his negative nature what
we're seeing what's wrong
critical eye yeah critical the first
charge I had was judging my mom or for
you know being like a victim and stuff
and withholding love for that reason and
you decide to forgive me yeah that was
hard it took me a while as we go into
the moods tomorrow then we'll dig into
deeper deeper stuff foreign
we had also gone through hundreds of
questions about our emotions each time
we went in and based on an algorithm it
revealed what emotions we were
suppressing stubborn was a big one we
got stubborn it's connected to
impatience I optimized so much for for
productivity that I'm like no we're not
doing that what about miserable came up
three times well yeah I guess it comes
from being dissatisfied with my progress
with myself there's always that feeling
that
yeah
could have done more and as always what
I felt for my dad oh you did this good
but you're doing some of this stuff so
you feel like you're enough if I don't
do these things what do I have to offer
then what things you need to forgive
your dad for
eign
let's say that you go in to take a test
and you've just found out that your
girlfriend has left you your dog at home
has been run over and your mother's had
a stroke how well are you going to do on
that test now these are obvious things
but everybody holds on to grudges and so
when you clear out the emotional pain
then you can think better I don't know
if you want to get it to now you know
your experience in high school as well
that you didn't didn't really tell
anyone about you said yeah just like I
mean they're just kids you know but
getting bullied for a few years not
telling anyone in the family about it
yeah maybe some forgiving to be done
there okay just letting it go but one
bully or multiple bullets it was like a
group of six okay so we want to forgive
each one of them I mean but they're just
kids you know what I mean like I know
but blowing it off as though they were
just kids whatever they're still a part
of you that experience that there's
still that part of you that in a future
situation may take over and cause you to
feel anxiety fear worry until you do
forgiveness on that you know it could
pop up at any time when you're
unexpected it's funny how this is all
about trauma in your past and
daddy issues I'm like where's the IQ
stuff
I'm getting more familiar with this room
now it's a different world that you're
entering imagine you're going into your
brain it's completely dark here and you
just hear your brain singing and you see
emotions coming up and this is the room
where I do the work in a way it's like
forced progress
and I did a forgiveness
on myself for letting myself be
overweight when I was in high school got
bullied because of that you like all
this just silly stuff the first one was
your dad and what was the judge it's
just multiple ones never being satisfied
judging other people harshly and cutting
them off which then created a fear in me
to tell them how I really feel because I
didn't want to become one of his enemies
yeah it was really rough yesterday that
last session I was so close to bailing
if I knew that this program was about
raising your Consciousness and
spirituality and forgiveness I don't
know if I would have signed up for this
I feel the exact same way the crazy
thing is like all the benefits that we
spoke about for this thing that's a
byproduct of doing the Forgiveness work
just wish it wasn't so hard
I mean we're still going to see how much
our IQ increased once we do the final
test how do you sleep not bad not bad
catch up on your rest a little bit yeah
good for you guys good for you guys
um I had a really weird dream last night
I was feeling really tired and I was
worried about I was gonna get sick like
I needed some immune support so I went
into the kitchen and there I saw it
the sponsor of this video can you know
that a bit higher like more like this
just one simple scoop a day mix it up
and drink it
[Music]
30 day Carnival experiment I stopped
eating liver because it tastes horrible
so to cover all my nutritional needs
I've been drinking ag1 by athletic
greens
actually let me just do it it's okay
okay if you use the link below you get
five free travel packs with your first
purchase
okay a yearly supply of vitamins and
like most items you order online it
comes in
which you could also use for stuff if
you wanted to I guess like a recycling
hobby
click the link below and take your
health to the next level
yeah and that's when I woke up
anyways what's next typically you know
we see around day three they're hit a
Wall of Resistance I think you told me
the story once where your dad would let
your sisters win but it would beat you
he wouldn't let me win because otherwise
I wouldn't learn how to get better so do
you feel like you're holding back when
it comes to winning yeah okay sounds
ridiculous saying it out loud you know
it sounds so silly but like I'll play
chess with my wife's dad right and I'm
winning too much I feel bad because like
a respect thing I'm like okay then I'll
I'll pull back now lose the game
it's so mentally taxing man my brain is
like genuinely a headache right now oh I
was struggling by the end I just wanted
to get out of there
so what's the biggest Gap right now for
you
I can make a guess I'm trying to dig you
said you wanted to go deep so
yeah I think just the whole thing of
being hot on myself what's the
underlying condition
I look at what's wrong yeah what needs
to be fixed yeah and uh yeah I think it
comes from my dad what he did to me I'm
doing to myself now
and to forgive my dad and myself good
that's great
there's no accident that you both are
doing the training together and it comes
down to enoughness of not feeling enough
and so really digging down to find where
you set up this pattern of not being
enough
yeah
ref and I was saying before this that
all the stuff that we do productivity
working on a business going after our
goals all of that comes after this meta
believe that we have which is yeah we're
kind of not good the way we are right
now and we're going to be happy later
this is like the foundation the soil
that everything grows out of if we are
to change that that changes everything
that we do everything that we believe
like our entire reality changes
I want to make that transformation yeah
because I don't want to be another guy
who posts videos on YouTube and then
reinforces this oh we gotta get
somewhere guys I have responsibility
here
I think you can get rid of that the mean
to be productive it would change your
entire life
[Music]
the last day is the day that people
break through because we'll be looking
at the emotions we resist the most what
is the Breakthrough are you think you're
gonna have today I don't know I feel a
bit heavy this morning do you think uh
you're done with the what happened in
high school yeah for now one of the
things you mentioned yesterday as well
was that you are afraid of like
something happening in public I don't
want to talk about that yeah that's
that's a that's far more personal it's
like just being attacked in public bro
let's say you put a YouTube video out
you know the negative comments that's
like in a public Arena getting attacked
and things like that yeah it ties into
just like being liked caring what people
think you know making sure everybody's
good good and chill
good morning excited I'm pumped I want
there to be like a transformation I can
feel like I'm in the cusp of it but I
don't want this to be like a blip in an
experience in my life and the only way I
can do that is to really get that
breakthrough I think that's completely
possible
be careful what you wish for
anytime you're facing resistance you
have power there's there's also well it
shows you where the Gap is the first
thing that popped up for me is I can't
be average what's the underlying
condition
[Music]
what aren't you enough I don't know like
the whole word enough doesn't resonate
with me I don't want to be enough what
do you want to be exceptional maybe yes
exceptional okay yeah because enough is
like yeah he's enough it's like oh yeah
I don't know where this would possibly
come from though yeah maybe it's because
you want to achieve these things so you
don't end up alone I feel like the more
I got these things the more the only it
gets I mean I lost most of my friends
when I started
my business and stuff it's almost like
being contrarian on purpose yeah because
I want to be different than other people
because I don't belong to them yeah if
you want to be different you don't
belong to people how can you be
interested in them as a person
how can you expect yourself to help the
masses if you can't relate to them
yeah
I want the connection I want to relate
to people I want to feel like I fit in
but I feel like I can't so I go the
opposite route yeah when I was 14 15. I
hated everything mainstream I just felt
like I couldn't be one of the good guys
so I had to be the villain I wanted to
be the villain not the villain that's
evil but the villain that's just
misunderstood and that's why when I
watch movies if there's a villain that
has a good motive I always feel for him
like silco in Arcane that guy he just
wants the best for his people he just
doesn't have the right strategies to to
get there I can always find differences
between people that's a never-ending
game to play well I'll always be
different and I'll always be alone
I think I found some [ __ ] down here so
that's all it is is past decisions
thoughts and emotions you've had are
basically causing you to resist
something that's in your environment now
the thing we talked about on the way
here I don't want to talk about that
yeah that's that that's a that's I think
when it comes to the bully stuff there's
resistance there yeah part of the reason
I don't want to talk about it on this
video or I mentioned that maybe I don't
want to talk about it because I don't
want to be seen as a victim I've got
like a real resistance to being a victim
I don't want to need help when he said
it you could feel him like ah but if you
are helpless what if you are a victim
yeah see your reaction here is like yeah
your reaction is like
I just don't like that mentality it's
like being a victim is a choice like you
get to choose to be a victim or a Victor
and it's like if I tell myself I'm a
victim then I'm helpless and if I'm
helpless and I need help and I don't
want to need help I can just do myself
just like resonating with victimhood
like that it's not about resonating with
victim but it's not about being a victim
it's about accepting that at times
you've been a victim whether you like it
or not that's what you're resistant
because if you weren't we wouldn't be
having this conversation put your arms
out and stiff armor right step on me
right yeah so if I'm all these things of
your resistance yeah who's in control
right now there is no sense but when you
release and I'm still pushing you're not
focusing those things who's in control I
mean I'm literally not moving exactly
all the time that we're resistance we're
stiff on
so breaths again yeah you can feel it's
I get it it's the same thing for me it's
just other things yeah oh it's so
frustrating because it's like no Shadow
to hide in this all comes down to
courage really because if not now when
this is the hour this is like the the
final hour to really do this and the
question is do you want to be free
that looks like exactly I mean think
about all the great gifts and lessons
that came from this you not wanting to
be a victim I think that's what made you
so ambitious and and it made you focus
on the strength in other people
give them hope like it's one of your
greatest qualities man
I mean like Leon hit the nail on the
head it's like and so I want to give
people hope
yeah
so sad they help you
oh there's it's like
I just want to help you know make them
feel Worthy
you could do so much
so I can't see myself as a victim
because it's like who's gonna be their
Rock who's gonna be their Australia
I'm just gonna show them hey look at all
this stuff that you've done look how far
you've gotten yeah I believe you yes I
do I really feel it's not just worth
yeah that's what I see the most in Wrath
yeah you just see that he's always that
sure you are so it's like hey you can do
this yeah you know because you can yeah
you can do it you know yeah that's the
greatest quality man
I love you bro love you
yeah
I'm curious uh
how are you gonna look after today and
how your brain is gonna look too yeah
you're gonna feel
last training this whole thing really
makes you think who do you have to
forgive or what are you trying to avoid
that you just won't accept
okay gentlemen this is your last chamber
session I was a victim at one point in
my life that's okay and when other
people feel like a victim that's okay I
can help more people coming to the
situation home and the more I win the
more other people win
just knowing that I can connect with
anyone I have more in common
with everyone than having differences
why are we even here for the IQ thing
while even here you know it's like I
came here for this and now seeing all
this other stuff that we've worked on
this is what I'm gonna put this doesn't
matter anymore exactly it's like that
was like such a small game and this is
like this is foundational they tricked
us into this I know I'm glad that we got
tricked but
we're still gonna see yes if our IQ
increase I will do it we'll do it why
not but like this time I just don't go
like I just don't care
yo your head's looking pretty big bro is
that the big brain you're holding in
there what's been your experience since
I've just been like ridiculously more
productive the biggest thing that's
changed for me is how I relate to people
I've been able to connect with people so
much better and the lens through which I
view the world has changed what's the IQ
it increased fairly significantly 23 IQ
points what no yeah actually 23 for
context we had more confidence doing it
the second time it's hard to know what
was because of the training and what was
because we got used to what an IQ test
looks like for me there was a six point
increase but at this point who the [ __ ]
cares
foreign